hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown americans facing
yet another anxiety-filled holiday
season as federal officials warn there
could be a massive wave of covid19
infections by january fox news anchor
bill hammer weighs in on the current
uptick in virus cases and speculation
over whether president biden will run
again in 2024 and despite growing fears
surrounding the coronavirus the
transportation security administration
estimates the volume of passengers at
airports nationwide through december
will approach pre-pandemic levels
aviation expert mike boyd shares his
insight on whether airlines and airports
are ready for the busy travel week ahead
plus fox across america host jimmy fayla
shares his thoughts on the world's
richest person elon musk being chosen as
time magazine's person of the year
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we take a deeper look at
the stories important to you you can
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
i'm emily compagno i'm guy benson i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
friday december 17 2021 i'm chris foster
the new omicron coronavirus variant may
spread faster but get most people less
sick which has fox's bill hammer
cautiously optimistic when they mutate
and get stronger that's bad news for us
when they mutate and get weaker we know
the virus itself is running its course
and eventually sooner more than later
will die out i'm lisa brady the latest
covet surge isn't stopping the holiday
rush the ceo of frontier airlines quite
correctly said people are getting kind
of burned out on this coba thing and i
think they're more and more willing to
take a chance you want to call it that
taking trips in the future
and i'm jimmy fella i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
christmas eve is a week from tonight
after a lot of americans skip seeing
friends and family last year because of
the coronavirus pandemic and vaccines
around the corner coven 19 deaths and
hospitalizations are on the rise now and
some of those people who had been
feeling like things were back to normal
also have concerns about this new
omicron variant white house chief
medical advisor dr anthony fauci says
booster shots are recommended but what
we have works our booster vaccine
regimens work
against omicron at this point there is
no need for a variant specific
booster and even for a lot of people
who've been taking the virus seriously
it's back to christmas as usual i'm
gonna get together with my family and um
i'm not gonna have a lot of concern bill
hammers the co-host of america's
newsroom weekday mornings 9-11 eastern
on fox news channel i've been vaccinated
i've had the booster so too as just
about everybody in my family i think if
not everyone got a few young young
youngans in the in the crowd who uh have
probably not likely gone in for it
um
listen i i i listen to the experts i
listen to people like dr mark segal i
you know he's been studying this stuff
for 20 years and when i've got a
question about what i'm going to do i
call them and i said what do you think
about this that and the other
he he
very early on said the vaccine was the
best vaccine that humankind had ever
made uh with the mrna and when he said
that that made an impact on me and i i
trust him and i take him for his word
i will say that i feel immeasurably more
comfortable because i feel i have been
protected
through the vaccine
this past week i was at madison square
garden you've got 18 19 000 people there
and they're checking the vaccination
status people go inside i don't know how
they did it actually
i think some of the ushers were kind of
passives yeah
shall i suggest but i felt comfortable
being there and if people wanted to wear
a mask they could do it um i i think the
days of wearing a mask fortunately will
continue to dwindle in the new year
that's my feeling
with this omnicron the early sense is
that it's more transmissible but maybe
less severe
especially if you're vaccinated it seems
to me that this may be another case
where
the unvaccinated are going to be even
more in trouble here because because
this variant is going to go through
those communities pretty quickly yeah i
think that is a possibility and if you
listen to the experts that's the that's
the warning out there delta was
contagious and it seems to be more
harmful than
omicron
and if you follow the news out of south
africa it it has not changed much over
the past couple of weeks
they said the world was overreacting
uh they said it was most cases were mild
they said in
most cases there was no hospitalization
required
they said the trend for them seems to be
diminishing
now i know it's early on that but it
seems to be heading in that direction if
that's true in south africa and if we're
dealing with the same new variant here
in the united states
i would expect you know although highly
contagious but not nearly as lethal or
harmful
so my guess is sometime around
mid-january toward the end of next month
we're gonna we're gonna have a pretty
good handle on this latest variant and
then we'll see what else is out there
but i think generally speaking listeners
need to follow what we have learned
about viruses when they mutate
and get stronger that's bad news for us
when they mutate and get weaker we know
the virus itself is running its course
and eventually sooner more than later
will die out back to christmas uh how
about presents now we were warned months
ago you better order early mail stuff
early um
because of the problems with the with
the supply chain and whatnot for me it's
been so far so good around here how
about you yeah uh that's my experience i
think so far so good as well uh there
was there was one gift that i was
getting from a high-end store in new
york for a person that i had to buy a
high-end gift for
to be honest with you and uh it's not
available yet and they they said
give us your email we'll send you the
email when it's in so i'm waiting on
that i don't know when it comes in i
doubt if it will be for the holidays so
that might be one of those things that
gets stuck up in the system that we do
not see until the new year but other
than that i agree with you i think so
far it's been pretty good stuff's more
expensive now uh not just high-end stuff
but okay we won't know this month's
number for a bit but last month had a
6.8 annual inflation rate 6.8 percent uh
this new fox business poll has a lot of
americans blaming president biden for
this
inflation signed a lot of countries but
it's higher here
now the president says it's a priority
but i'm not sure what he is doing about
her and what he realistically can do
about it yeah my feeling was it could be
a long answer interrupt me whenever you
want on the port system going back to
the supply issue i i i felt as if
somebody in the administration maybe was
pete but a jed she would be the likely
candidate there should have been in the
port of long beach you should have been
in the port of la saying we're on the
job we're going to figure it out
um i i think that would have been a good
strong message to the american people
and to the world that did not happen i
don't know why
with regard to inflation this is a nasty
bug we've got here and the problem is we
don't know how much worse it could get
but we have seen what is done already
and the level of concern is provided
also now the fed this past week came out
with their plan for the new year in my
opinion it was not hawkish enough i
would have liked to have seen them do
something immediately now they will do
something the coming weeks about buying
fewer bonds by the month what they've
been doing a lot of and then we expect
three interest rate hikes in the new
year well when interest rates are at
zero three interest rate hikes are it's
not a lot
but being an amateur economist i
m my position is
go ahead and make the bump now
arm yourself with greater weapons
so not knowing what's around the corner
will fortify you with a greater arsenal
to go on the offensive and i think when
you're at zero interest rates you lack
that ability to do it i mean japan's
been doing this since the 1990s and it
hasn't worked real well so that that's
what i'd like to have seen with regard
to the president
um my criticism would be well my
observation is
that joe manchin has got in the way of
buildback better and who knows how many
other democratic senators
are with manchin on this i think it's a
high likelihood there could be three or
four or five who are thinking too much
too fast
you say it's 1.7 trillion cbo says it's
more like 4 trillion even if it's
somewhere in the middle do we need that
level of spending now
when we're dealing with the issues of
price controls and inflation
then you consider what they passed in
march in the 1.9 trillion dollars that
were passed the american rescue plan
toward the end of march probably was not
the greatest move
um it was it was a ton of money
and
i would suggest it probably let us down
the inflation road
faster than we would have gone otherwise
that's my view yeah no doubt and the
buildback better at least is is spread
out now
the plan
that they seem to have settled on so far
this may have to be next was to fund a
lot of stuff temporarily
uh and just hope that politically it has
to it has to stick they may end up and
end up being better off just picking a
couple priorities like maybe the stuff
for kids like the tax credit or pre-k
and make that permanent and say and this
is our message this is what we've done
for you the american people yeah um i i
could
i i guess you're right i mean that's
that's a possibility i i think you might
have a civil war within the party
i think there are progressives in the
house and the few in the senate who
um
are
all in
on getting
everything
in the law that was in this
massive bill
if they go that route i would suggest
there will be a lot of hesitation
a lot of disappointment
um what i think biden has been trying to
do for the past year is keep the party
together
and
if they go that route that might be a
sure-fire way to create a fissure within
the democratic party which i believe
then would be one of the most critical
political stories of 2022 in the new
year and something that everybody needs
to pay attention to because then the
warts would come out we'd see all of it
between um
uh between the progressives and the
moderates in the democratic party and
well if they don't pass anything at all
uh that's going to hurt him in 2022 as
well so it's maybe you know listen there
are some analysts already saying that
the best thing possible is to make sure
that the filibuster stays intact and
make sure that buildback better doesn't
pass and that that would allow the
economy to take its course and we'll see
what comes from that and that might
allow uh joe biden some breathing room
uh
not to pass something in a 50 50 senate
and a nearly 50-50 house yeah um the
president's approval rating is about 44
on average uh president trump this time
during his presidency i looked it up
this morning uh december of 2021
uh sure 37 43 ah
um and he ended up you know losing in
2020 but it's early time still but you'd
rather be more popular than where joe
biden is now where donald trump was then
yes my feeling is it's uh a good parlor
game to think about 2024
but it is entirely to if you and i were
flying to the moon tonight that that
would be that would be the distance of
travel that it would take us to get
there and that's kind of like when
political years what we're dealing with
there's plenty of time for buying to
turn this thing around uh there's plenty
of time to get certain issues sorted
but that will not stop the media during
what others would consider a somewhat
slow news time
uh to talk about it well that's exactly
right i mean i'm i'm guilty of it you're
probably guilty of it in certain
segments i mean
uh there's al already talk about well
who's gonna run in 2024 it's not going
to be biden
uh i mean policy fan or not though he's
he is going to be 82 right after the the
next election day the second term when
he's 86 i mean i know it's just sort of
idle speculation now but it's fair
but he has said just this past week in
fact that he he assured people that he
will be the candidate in 2024. now
listen that can all change in the next
three years but i mean if you're a
sitting president what you don't want to
say is i'm a one-termer and i'm done
because if that's the case other people
going to be taking shots from you from
the other party from your own party and
your chances of getting greater
legislation passed diminish in my view
bill hammer thanks a lot man uh host of
america's newsroom along with diana
perino 9 to 11 eastern mornings on fox
news channel bill always a pleasure
merry christmas good to be with you you
too
[Music]
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
if christmas is anything like
thanksgiving the roads and the airports
will soon be crowded
aaa expects more than 109 million people
to travel at least 50 miles from home up
more than one-third over last year and
for airlines nearly triple the number of
holiday travelers assuming omicron
doesn't spark a widespread change of
plans
more than once over thanksgiving week
tsa screenings topped 2 million in a
single day a pandemic record at a senate
hearing on wednesday executives from
several major airlines thanked lawmakers
for more than 50 billion dollars in
taxpayer-funded relief after covid
largely grounded the travel industry
last year i want to state it succinctly
and unequivocally the payroll support
program has been an overwhelming success
american airlines ceo doug parker says
the program saved the airline industry
but there have been some staffing issues
as travel has rebounded especially for
american and southwest which each had
major disruptions this fall
parker says they couldn't fill extra
shifts quickly enough to adjust to
issues like unusual weather
we just didn't have the we don't have
the ability to recover as quickly so are
the airlines ready for the rest of the
holiday season oh yeah they're perfectly
ready for them mike boyd is a former
airline executive now a consultant and
president of boyd group international
the only thing that can happen is if
there's a snowstorm over chicago or over
dallas fort worth or a connecting hub
like that that'll screw things up but
that can do that anytime
we're looking at probably a situation
where the uh
the christmas holiday is going to go
fairly smoothly
some people might be surprised to hear
that only because of
recent disruptions in the run-up to
thanksgiving
especially
some articles and pundits that maybe
tried to tie it to
labor shortages and
even vaccine mandates um
there's kind of been give and take on
that
well the reality is we had southwest
airlines had an event where air traffic
control shut down
large parts of the southeast where a
good portion of their fleet goes that
messed them up badly the same thing with
american airlines with a weather event
at their biggest hub of dallas fort
worth that can always happen but
remember there's not a labor shortage
what shortage might be there is really
not enough pilots when things really get
out of whack where a pilot's stuck and
must just say sarasota for three hours
and he can't get to atlanta to get his
next flight going out to chicago that
screwed things up for hours but it's not
necessarily a case of not people being
able to load an airplane
and so when it comes to recent
disruptions
it sounds like you don't really
attribute any of the issues
to mandates pandemic related mandates
oh no not at all we don't know what
happened with southwest airlines when we
had an air traffic control issue whether
the faa had a had some sort of a
a labor issue at the jacksonville center
we don't know but as far as the airline
industry goes no i mandates have nothing
to do with it
some major airlines have just recently
announced plans to hire thousands more
people is that a continuing recovery
from the pandemic furloughs
well sure because a lot of people who
were furloughed just didn't want to come
back
the other issue is we you know we do
have an issue with pilot training and
flight attendant training but remember
you can't go out to laguardia airport
and start throwing bags right away for
an airline there's training that is
mandated to have to go through so it
takes time but yeah they're going to be
hiring because it looks like 2022
domestically will be a pretty strong
year won't be like 2019 but it's going
to be about 873 million people getting
on airplanes
when we hear about a peak travel day
with more than 2 million tsa screenings
it sounds like things are pretty normal
so how far off is the airline industry
or the travel industry more broadly from
where it was before the pandemic all
right well just the number 2019
we had about 983 million people getting
on airplanes this year we're going to
have about 630 million that's way down
uh you know 986 million
next year we're gonna have about 870
million so the industry is smaller
there's no question about it for a
variety of reasons but you know what
airplanes don't get packed they get full
what they're not the seventh avenue
subway when they have all 130 seats
occupied they're full
and those numbers
you're talking domestically or or
globally travel no this is on us
airports again in
2019 had 986 million people getting on
airplanes that's not passengers that's
people boarding the passenger number was
closer to about 700 million because you
know a lot of passengers make two
emplainments but
that's the volume going through airports
then it's going to be way down this year
but up from last year the next year will
be up but it's not going to be back to
2019 levels for a couple years
i know business travel isn't what it
once was i mean they're just you know
doing so much more remotely
at least for now but some that's
something that might continue going
forward
well you know the issue of remote travel
business travel was declining before the
pandemic hit i mean um you know an
example was you had about 40 000
business travelers 30 years ago going
between albany and boston today there's
nobody why because you don't need to
travel air travel's role as a
communication channel has changed things
like electronic meetings far more
effective in many many cases and that's
that's been accelerated by the pandemic
but it was coming anyway
one thing that hasn't changed uh are the
costs besides the ticket price like
baggage fees does this surprise you i
mean should they be doing more to coax
travelers back
well i think you know we mere mortals
cannot dream of the kind of fees
airlines will be dreaming up in the
future nevertheless it is a part of
their revenue stream
and again if there are people that will
tell you if i don't check a bag why
should i pay for somebody else to check
a bag kind of a specious argument but
that's what they're getting to but to
your point i believe southwest airlines
is making hundreds of millions of
dollars more because they don't charge
for luggage and they don't have change
fees so more people fly them and i think
that might be a lesson for other
airlines to look at the faa and the
industry have been warning about
potential disruptions
as wireless carriers begin to use the
c-band spectrum for 5g services
something which right now is being
delayed
what exactly is the danger here can you
kind of put that into layman's terms for
us well anybody's computer has ever been
hacked and tell you all about it
the fact is that we have a system that
makes our air transportation system less
safe possibly or vulnerable to hacking
that has to be dealt with before we go
any further uh you know 5g is wonderful
stuff but if it puts our air
transportation system at risk to someone
hacking or just simply not being as
efficient as it could be it's got to be
delayed
is it an issue also of
possibly interfering with the
instruments
on the planes in flight is that part of
the issue
as i understand if there's all kinds of
issues with it where it could affect the
safe operation of airplanes but again
there's also the security side of this
as well but again those have to be
addressed because you know again when
airplanes today flying were designed
let's say 20 years ago there was no 5g i
don't think there was a 1g so we we've
got to look at what our technology is
and how we can use that technology and
we have a long way to go i think for 5g
the wireless companies say this is just
fear-mongering that it's already being
done in nearly 40 other countries
so would you ultimately expect a
solution on on this issue well there'll
be a solution but keep in mind you know
these uh wireless companies have a lot
of dogs in the fight financially and
they're going to fight to tell you it
isn't really accurate i i would take the
word of the faa and airlines you know
over a wireless operator and they mean
well but the fact is if there's even a
hint of a problem we shouldn't do it
it seems like something that maybe will
be debated for a while yet
um
are you concerned at all about the
potential outcome i mean let's say if
the fcc and the faa
and the airlines you know can all get
together and work it out how confident
would you feel about whatever the
solution is
i'll be very confident because this is
clearly a technical issue there's no
politics involved there's nothing else
involved other than the technologies
involved so if they come up with
something i will guarantee you it'll be
probably as safe as a hand to man can
make it
what about this new covid variant it's
really thrown a wrench into things
reimposed mask mandates in various
states and various countries um
canada came out this week the health
minister there and told people look
avoid non-essential travel abroad
if you can
because it's spreading so rapidly that
would seem to be just what the travel
industry does not need
it's kind of a double-edged sword in the
sense that it is they don't need this
right now and more and more countries
are going to level four the high risk in
the eu now here in the us i think we're
a little more rational i don't know how
much more rational about dealing with it
but what we have now is a lot of people
who are going to take vacations in
europe
read this stuff and say i'm going to go
to boca raton instead so it could be
sort of a backhanded way of getting more
people on on flights this summer taking
vacations
but it is a concern
but
to this point it doesn't look like it's
another variant that's going to be
really critical and another point it
needs to be made i think it was the
barry biffle the ceo of frontier
airlines quite correctly said people are
getting kind of burnt out on this covet
thing and i think they're more and more
willing to take a chance you want to
call it that taking trips in the future
what is your advice for travelers at
this point as they navigate not only
this holiday season but the ongoing
pandemic
well the ongoing pandemic we don't know
i mean like for example wearing masks on
airplanes caroline ceos just told the
senate that these masks don't make any
sense and they don't because we don't
know what a mask is there's no
definition
and that means with there's no real
definition of how effective it is or
isn't but things like that don't help
air travel my feeling with people though
if if you have that mandate and the
airlines have to enforce it understand
it's not the airline's rule and don't
beat up the flight attendant that would
be my first number one suggesting to
anybody flying the people walking up and
down the aisle at the airline are not
the ones who are making you wear a mass
somebody else's mike boyd former airline
executive now consultant and president
of boyd group international thank you
very much for your time thank you
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
for this week's good news we take you to
the world of international sports
specifically football and when i say
football i mean soccer one of the most
heartwarming traditions in the sport
happened this week when fans of spanish
top flight club real peres brought teddy
bears and cuddly toys to a game to be
donated to underprivileged kids and if
you're thinking that they'd drop the
items in a collection bin out front or
something think again the real betas
fans have a tradition of throwing the
toys onto the soccer pitch during
halftime this one was during their match
with real sociedad fans are asked to
bring soft toys no larger than 35
centimeters about thirteen inches tall
and with no batteries included the place
was packed with more than fifty two
thousand people in the stands and when
the annual event was over about nineteen
thousand teddy bears and cuddly toys
were on the pitch
picture it the green soccer pitch was
littered with thousands of them in
bright colors soft brown teddy bears as
well as pink and yellow ones large panda
bears a cow a dinosaur several unicorns
even a stuffed purple octopus a rainfall
of cute cuddly toys while bobby helms
jingle bell rock played in the
background it was also a bit of teamwork
involved when the toys were thrown from
the upper seats folks in the lower deck
picked them up and threw them onto the
pitch and when it looks like they're
running out of toys they just keep
coming it's one of the best videos you
will see this week the real bettest fans
look like they're having a big time a
feeling that undoubtedly got better when
their team won four to nothing tanya j
powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy fallon
what's on your mind so elon musk has
been named time magazine's person of the
year he follows in the footsteps of last
year's winner joe biden who could win it
again this year because it turns out you
can't be person of the year if you don't
know what year it is okay so that was a
cheap shot at the president but in my
defense it's the only thing cheap given
the inflation he's caused elon musk
caused all of us to look towards a day
where commercial space travel is a real
possibility thanks to his spacex rockets
think about it pretty soon et won't have
to phone home he'll catch an uber thanks
to elon musk he might even take some
bitcoin with him now that must
mainstream the digital currency by
tweeting and talking about it all the
time sure none of us understand how it
works but we've all heard of it by now
it's like the kardashians of currency
meaning we don't know why it's worth so
much money but man does it get around
but it was musk's decision to relocate
his company from the over-taxed
over-regulated state of california to
freedom-loving texas that won me over i
don't use bitcoin and the way i'm eating
this month i'm never going to fit into
one of his spacesuits but if more people
follow his lead in pushing back on
government regulations and mandates
pretty soon this whole country will be
cleared for liftoff i'm jimmy fala
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
new from the fox news podcast network my
name is kennedy and welcome to my
podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome it's kennedy saves the world
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes